college graduates waking up this morning
without a care in the world no class
anymore
unlv and the csn graduates no alarm
clock until they start the job hunt
so no more class no more late night
study sessions but you do have to enter
the workforce and bianca holmen joining
us live with some tips for those who are
looking for a job
hey good morning so yeah now is the time
to secure a position and start paying
the bills so we checked in with the
career services departments here at unlv
and csn so here's some tips that they
gave us for all of our recent grads so
they tell us that the job market is
healthy majority of employers have
entry-level jobs and internships for
recent graduates
even with a lot of options that can be
overwhelming with for students
it's very much an employee's market
right now however career experts say
that that doesn't mean to wait around
graduates should still be proactive
no matter what that's the power of
education more educated we are
the more
the less likely artificial intelligence
takes over because it's all about um and
employers are looking for this critical
thinking
a high level of communication skills
problem solving is now very top of the
list
now there are sites like indeed or the
department of labor that you can explore
to understand job descriptions and
salary expectations
this research can help you create a
realistic plan for your first position
which may end up being an internship if
you have little to no experience now
coming up in the next half hour we're
going to hear about some places and
resources available for recent graduates
across the valley reporting live bianca
holman live local now you